I think particularly in poker emotion
also helps you become a better player so
you know as a poker player you have to
constantly find strike a strike a
balance between caring about your result
and not caring about your result right
so if you care too much and the thought
of losing hurts too much then you're
completely risk averse and you play too
cheaply and and you're almost paralyzed
at the table you can't you can't ever
make it you can't ever make a bet that
you're not sure you know would win that
would be the totally involved totally
emotional can't stand ever losing even a
pod right now you know that type of
player that Brandon described who you
know might blow his entire bankroll or
might have a you know a big Lawson you
can hardly tell I I think not only is
that player risking their entire bank
roll in a way that is very
self-destructive but I also would would
gather that that person maybe isn't
getting better the way they could so if
you manage your risk and you understand
as you know that you somehow managed to
find that happy medium where you're
willing to take some risk you're willing
to take some losses but at the end of
the session when you've lost your kind
of upset about it i mean you care deeply
about the fact that you lost that really
kind of motivates you and inspires you
to figure out what went wrong and you
know play that much tougher the next
time you play and and and and be a
better player the next time you play i
think if you don't care about the losses
then there's no real incentive to become
a better one
you